[Música]
hora de hablar de medio ambiente en
france 24
yo soy la calle y es un gusto
saludarles y hoy hablaremos de la crisis
energética global que ha provocado el
aumento de los combustibles fósiles a
pesar de que los países se han
comprometido a reducir las energías
provenientes del carbón del gas y del
petróleo la reactivación económica tras
los confinamientos de la pandemia
incrementó la demanda de energía a un
punto que las reservas no esperaban esto
provocó que los precios se dispararan en
europa por ejemplo que es el continente
más afectado el precio del gas aumentó
cerca de un 400 por ciento en lo que va
del año y el del petróleo ha subido más
del 60 por ciento en el mundo todo esto
ha obligado a varios de los países más
contaminantes a acelerar su producción
de carbón a pesar de que contamina el
doble que el gas en estados unidos ya
hay estimaciones de que este año se
producirá un 22% más de carbón que en el
2020 esto es un aumento que no se veía
desde el 2014 y china también aceleró la
energía basada en carbón la mayoría de
las provincias del país han tenido
apagones y se la respuesta fue 6
instrucciones oficiales una de ellas es
que las minas de carbón produzcan todo
lo que puedan y que comiencen a operar
también las minas a cielo abierto que ya
tienen la aprobación del gobierno el
problema es que entre más carbón más
contaminación y más lejos están de
alcanzar las promesas de neutralidad de
carbono para 2060 como lo dijo china o
la meta de depender únicamente de
energías renovables para el 2035 como lo
planteó eeuu sin embargo expertos como
manuel pulgar vidal de wwf creen que
esto es una situación coyuntural que no
implicará aplazar los compromisos
ambientales
el proceso lanzado por el acuerdo de
parís es irreversible e indetenible va a
ser difícil va a tener obstáculos pero
nadie lo detiene y estoy seguro que se
cumplirá lo segundo es que estos
problemas hay que ver dos analógica de
seguridad energética de hecho tenemos
que mejorar nuestros mecanismos de
cooperación porque hasta el día de hoy
la seguridad energética nos lleva a
recurrir a la fuente más disponible y
más alcanzable y lamentablemente a veces
con pocas consideraciones climáticas
pero lo tercero es que esto lo vamos
también a poder evitar utilizando
mecanismos complementarios hay que tener
en cuenta que políticas como la de preso
al carbono o políticas como la que la
unión europea está adoptando de ajuste
de carbono en fronteras tienen por
objeto cambiar esos comportamientos
entonces la situación coyuntural de
incremento del precio del gas y del
petróleo que lleva al carbón no
significa que tengamos que aplazar las
metas que nos hemos planteado más aún
cuando todos sabemos que estamos en la
denominada década decisiva parte de este
optimismo es que la crisis energética
nos lleve a impulsar las energías
renovables lo que suelen hacer los
países es que explotan la energía que
más tengan a la mano y que sea más
barata este es el caso del carbón en
indonesia en china o en el norte de
españa mientras que eeuu rusia e irán
son los mayores productores de gas del
mundo manuel pulgar vidal cree que los
altos precios de las energías fósiles de
combustibles son la coyuntura perfecta
para que el mundo le apueste más a las
energías renovables como la solar eso
las eólicas
mientras los países no entiendan que el
comportamiento de las economías está
cambiando significativamente por las
nuevas consideraciones climáticas
probablemente no van a tomar las medidas
adecuadas y la propia economía los va a
sancionar y van a tener una pérdida de
estructural de su producto bruto interno
y quedarán atrás mientras hay países que
sí entienden que estamos entrando a una
nueva economía del clima y que por lo
tanto la promoción de estas energías
renovables no convencionales es un deber
es una necesidad por eso es tan
importante no solamente que los países
tengan planes climáticos al 2030 claro
solo que se llaman las contribuciones
nacionalmente determinadas sino también
su visión al 2050 si conectamos las
medidas de corto plazo de esta década
con una visión de que queremos ser el
2050 los países van a poder promocionar
las fuentes de energía que necesitan
para alcanzar su propia sostenibilidad
un escenario para mostrar estas
experiencias es la cob 26 declaró desde
el 31 de octubre reino unido- será el
anfitrión de la cumbre climática donde
los países establecerán sus nuevas metas
para intentar evitar que la temperatura
de la tierra aumente 15 grados celsius
para el 2030 pero también es el
escenario perfecto para mostrar cómo se
puede hacer la transición energética la
reciente crisis ha puesto a reino unido
en una encrucijada si le apuesta a las
energías renovables y detiene el
desarrollo petrolero en el mar del norte
dependerá más del combustible y del gas
importado una situación que ya lo está
poniendo contra las cuerdas por los
altos precios sin embargo hay
iniciativas como la apuesta por la
energía eólica en escocia nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido fue hasta la
ciudad escocesa de aberdeen allí
conversó con quienes lideran la mayor
iniciativa del país para acelerar la
transición energética y lograr las cero
emisiones de carbono ernesto en berlín
a quienes cosas estamos buscando cómo
traer toda la experiencia del petróleo y
el gas cómo hacer grandes proyectos
offshore y transferir esa experiencia
por ejemplo las turbinas eólicas
flotantes mucha tecnología es parecida
para trabajar debajo del agua y en
condiciones submarinas de aguas
profundas hay buenos ejemplos sobre como
traer el conocimiento de las industrias
tradicionales y aplicarlos para acelerar
la transición hacia las industrias de
baja
carpenter in the streets seguramente
esta es una de las experiencias de las
que se hablará en la cob 26 el proyecto
se realiza especialmente en las islas
del norte de escocia como orkney y
shetland que durante años se han
beneficiado de los ingresos del petróleo
del mar del norte
ahora buscan alternativas energéticas a
medida que disminuyen las reservas y que
la crisis climática empeora y con esto
terminamos nuestro programa de hoy
recuerden que pueden consultar más
información ambiental en nuestro canal
de youtube en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom gracias por estar con
nosotros
[Música]